depuis plusieurs jours la sphère des
scandales sexuels dans le sport
soulevées par les révélations de sarah
abitbol victimes de viol de la part de
son entraîneur lorsqu'elle avait 15 ans
a déclenché un véritable tsunami chez
les sportifs supporté par les médias
notamment le journal l'équipe le
témoignage de cette ancienne patineuse
artistique a fait en quelques jours le
tour de la france
réveillant au passage de vieilles
blessures et beaucoup de non dits des
révélations qui ont poussé le parquet de
paris à ouvrir une enquête mais aussi la
ministre des sports a demandé la
démission de didier gailhaguet président
de la fédération française des sports de
glace qui aurait couvert les agissements
de l'entraîneur en question selon
plusieurs accusateurs aujourd'hui
l'homme accusé a décidé de s'exprimer
lors d'une conférence de presse
il faut une vraie capacité à encaisser
les coups et les coups bas plus
spécialement
je suis donc ici pour rétablir une
stricte vérité car j'ai bien compris qu
en démocratie il ne suffit pas d'avoir
raison
le faut aussi convaincre pour lui il n'a
commis aucune faute en ne licencions pas
gilles meyer malgré plusieurs
signalements il y a eu une enquête de
police l'a conclu que les faits qui
étaient qui lui étaient reprochés et
tête n'était pas avérée une affaire qui
va au-delà du monde du patinage car elle
lève dans le monde du sport de
nombreuses omerta aujourd'hui ce sont 54
sportifs qui ont décidé de porter leur
voix pour mettre fin à ces dérives parmi
eux teddy riner nathalie péchalat ou
encore sarah ourahmoune ont signé une
tribune pour dire stop
alors selon vous didier galas gay
aurait-il dû démissionner alors donc
didier garric qui ne démissionne pas
donc le président de la fédération
française de patinage et lors de sa
conférence de presse didier gailhaguet
on a profité pour régler ses comptes
notamment avec gwendal peizerat qui a
pris la parole dans les médias pour
demander sa démission
regarde alors si j'écoute les anciens
sportifs tels que gwendal peizerat par
exemple tout le monde savait tout le
monde mais tout le monde savait quoi que
des jeunes filles été violée mais que
diable ceux qui savaient donc il pas
dénoncé ces faits il est bien trop
facile de venir baver sur les plateaux
de télévision aujourd'hui et dire que
tout le monde savait et n'avoir rien dit
avant
enfin je n'ai pas oublié
aussi que le regretté eugène posera son
père était secrétaire général de cette
fédération
au moment des faits qui remontent à 30
ans alors justement gwendal peizerat et
la merci wendat d'état parce qu il
appelle à voter entre il vient vient
d'arriver gwendal merci d'être là vous
êtes un énorme champion six fois
champion de france deux fois champion
d'europe champion du monde médaillé d'or
aux jo de salt lake city en 2002 vous
considérez sarah abitbol comme votre
petite soeur et vous dit elle ne s'est
jamais confié à moi pas plus qu'à ses
parents elle a tout gâché enfui en elle
et vous à l'église avait déclaré le 3
février dernier sur rtl que tout le
monde était au courant du côté d'evian
de gilles beyer c'est ce qui vous est
reproché ici par didier gailhaguet
avant de donner la parole à à gwendal
merci encore d'être là qu'est ce que
vous dites
déjà le président de la fédération qui
démissionne pas que ce que vous en
pensez et après sur les propos qu'il a
sur wind lp de rater continue tout le
monde disait tout le monde le savent
alors pourquoi vous n'avez pas donc
c'est gilles j'ai trouvé que la
conférence de presse de didier gainey
était surréaliste sont en gros sa thèse
c'est pas moi c'est les autres c'est pas
moi c'est l'état mais même si il ne
réfute chaque fait il ya une
responsabilité morale quand vous êtes
président on a l'impression que lui il
est au dessus de tissage ne veut pas
l'entendre
pour moi il aurait dû démissionner c'est
une faute majeure il sera forcé de parer
et sur ce qui lie sur gwendal et sur les
clubs sportifs qui disent oui tous le
savent alors pourquoi ils n'ont pas dit
ah bon c'est inadmissible parce que
c'est un système qui étaient là c'est un
système qui est verrouillé je dirais
même que c'est un système qui est vérolé
par monsieur caillé gay et ses sbires
dans le comité exécutif de la fédération
tout était contrôlé les sportifs étaient
écartés monsieur pèsera il a voulu se
présenter à un moment il a été
blackboulé la même pub exposé son
programme
le système était verrouillée donc
maintenant il faut que le système soit
mathieu delormeau
évidemment qu'il doit démissionner parce
que de deux choses l'une soit il ne
savait vraiment pas et dans ce cas là
c'était un mauvais président du comité
pendant dix ans parce qu'il ne sait pas
ce qui se passait au sein de dieu du
comité soit il le savait et oui on est
tous d'accord qu'il entendait des
rumeurs et si encore plus immondes parce
qu'il les a tués pour que ça continue à
la télévision donc dans les deux cas il
doit quitter et dans les deux cas elle
de faire amende honorable
alors il active on va voir après ce
qu'il a dit contre la ministre mais eux
ou qui pensent qu'il aurait dû
démissionner qui pensent qu'il aurait
pas dû
démissionner jean-michel moi je trouve
sa position je suis désolé je suis je
suis pas dans les affaires internes de
la libération mais je trouve qu'il a une
position qui à cesson sais pas je les
écoute et il avait l'air sincère je sais
pas s'il est en tout cas je suis pas
pour que résistant du fusil le savent a
toujours considéré on vire quelqu'un qui
est coupable s'il n'est pas coupable
eh bien tant qu'il n'est pas coupable
ils purent être à sa place mais c'est
quoi tu veux dire quoi faire sauter
quelques uns dont on sait pas s'il est
coupable ou pas c'était bizarre oui
sophy il dit qu'ils savaient ils le
savaient puisqu'il a même demandé à
l'époque à la mise des sports à marie
george buffet de mener une enquête
puisqu'il avait reçu une lettre de
parents justement de plainte
la jeune fille venait d'en geste est une
jeune patineuse qui se plaignait
justement d'attouchements acceptera donc
y avait eu une enquête et jb hier avait
été écarté au clan trainer voilà il est
soupçonné
voilà c'est revoir comme il est revenu
et c'est bien justement les aigles et
qu'il a remis en place notamment avec
des jeunes des mesures notamment en
équipe junior etc pour les championnats
du monde en corée et il a dit il a
déclaré lors de la conférence de presse
je pensais qu'il avait changé
apparemment il n'a pas changé tellement
d'accord alors c'est un peu
il a poussé un gros coup de gueule
contre la ministre qui lui a demandé de
démissionner lundi regarde il m'est
demandé de démissionner à propos de
faits qui remontent à 30 ans c'est comme
si on demandait à madame la ministre de
démissionner parce que dans son propre
club de natation à clamart où il fait
trouver un pervers sexuel at elle
d'ailleurs diligenter une enquête
ces coups de balai il y a il faut le
faire déjà chez soi mais de qui se moque
t-on stigmatiser un président de
fédération
certes très imparfait mais honnête et
travailleur
c'est dégueulasse alors quid alpes et
drate merci encore d'être avec nous
quand vous avez vu cette conférence de
presse alors est ce qu il a dit
notamment sur vous et il assure la
ministre
qu'est ce que vous dites pour vous 10
des galas gay aurait dû démissionner
vous devrez démissionner oui devrait
démissionner évidemment évidemment qui
devrait démissionner tous présidents de
fédérations de par le monde
devant une histoire comme ça juste part
du décès bon sens par décence et bon
sens se mettrent air en arrière et
dirais ok et il ya eu des choses de fait
et ça n'aurait pas dû arriver c'est pas
le cas de didier gailhaguet
les amazighs gwendal peizerat que didier
gailhaguet avait été avertie par
plusieurs courriers notamment partie dié
lucine entraîneur à annecy qui a alerté
sur le comportement de gilles beyer
accusé d'agression sexuelle sur des
patineuses quand vous avez critiqué dit
des guerriers sur la gestion de la fédé
le viol c'est la partie visible de
l'iceberg
ce que vous ne voyez pas que nous vivons
depuis 20 ans c'est une somme de
violence psychologique de harcèlement
moral
c'est une lutte permanente pour essayer
de lutter contre cette fédération alors
oui il vous a répondu oui et tout ce
qu'ils disent
on le savait tous et baïse auraient dû
se manifester avant qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez
on s'est manifesté on s'est manifestée
tout le monde s'est manifestée pas sur
le viol
le viol a encore une fois c'est sûr des
choses qui mettent du temps à sortir
lancé le pourquoi
par contre ces violences psychologiques
danse parle dont je parle tout tout ce
harcèlement
il est quotidien tout le monde essaye de
faire changer ça à la fédé depuis depuis
depuis des années on s'est tous
regroupés en collectif d'anciens
sportifs non sarah philippe candeloro et
beaucoup d'autres c'est pas juste moi
c'est pas mon affaire
nous nous sommes nombreux et on s'est
tous mobilisés en 2014 pour essayer de
faire changer les choses on avait un
vrai projet on avait une envie de
proposer aux présidents de clubs
quelque chose de nouveau et le système
fait que voilà il maîtrise les plus gros
clubs et même si on a eu un maximum on a
une majorité de voix
enfin une majorité de présidents de
clubs qui ont voté pour nous mais pas
une majorité de voix parce que comme le
système américain
il ya des gros clubs dont beaucoup de
gros clubs parisiens qui sont à fait aux
dés à didier gailhaguet et qui ont voté
pour lui
oui parce que des casseroles c'est ça
c'est que sa moralité est les bleus
problème ne remonte pas avec elle qu'il
ya quatre il ya quatre jours c'est un
président qui a été évincée de la
fédération internationale qui étaient
interdits de patinoires pendant trois
ans il n'avait pas le droit de rentrer
dans une patinoire pendant trois ans il
revient il est réélu il a il a subi des
casseroles aussi sur tout ce qui est
financier le redressement de la
fédération française des sports de glace
durer des années et des années et des
années alors il attaque également votre
terre aux gènes eugène pèsera donc le
père de gwendal était secrétaire général
de la fédération au moment des faits il
était également une fille il est
également une figure appréciée du milieu
il est décédé en 2014
les suites d'une maladie en plein en
plein pendant la campagne justement que
l'on menait contredit les propos qu'il a
eu envers eux ça ne m'étonne pas
puisqu'il l'a déjà fait pendant la
campagne au moment où mon père est
décédé donc j'étais en plein deuil
il a fait passer un message au club en
disant attention monsieur me posera fait
en sorte de vous amadouer et de vous
apitoyer de faire en sorte que vous
apitoyer sur son sort parce qu'il vient
de perdre son père mon père était à
l'image de ben préaubert qui m'a soutenu
pendant la campagne un très très beau
sportif une belle personne et qui était
dans ce bureau exécutif
il faut pas faire un amalgame tout le
monde n'est pas mauvais dans la
fédération attention qui était dans son
bureau exécutif qui a démissionné
d'ailleurs il le faisait parce que après
notre échec de 2014 il se dit peut-être
qu'on peut changer les choses de
l'intérieur donc il était là pour
essayer de changer les choses de mon
père il a fait ça aussi
pendant des années il est il était à
lyon il montait deux jours par semaine à
la fédération pour s'occuper des
affaires administratives
il ne peut pas dire que mon père puisse
savoir exactement tout ce que savait
didier gailhaguet équipe à 75 eur par
par semaine à la fédération et qui ne
vit que de ça et surtout mais quelle
indécence
quelle indécence quelques lettres abject
que de s'attaquer à une personne décédée
qui aujourd'hui ne pourra pas répondre à
ces attaques et mais il n'a rien contre
moi il a contre plein de patineurs
contre plein d'entraîneurs et s'il fait
quelque chose ils peuvent perdre leur
boulot ils peuvent perdre leur passion
ils peuvent perdre
pour les juges le fait de pouvoir partir
en compétition et ne plus vivre leur
passion
moi je suis chef d'entreprise j'ai
d'autres choses à côté du patinage
j'ai pas besoin de ça et c'est pour ça
que didier gailhaguet il a peur de moi
et c'est pour ça que quand il veux
m'attaquer y tape sur ma famille c'est
ma mère qui souffre aujourd'hui le
le deuil de mon père et qu'on puisse
salir l'image de mon père tous les gens
qui sont dans cette fédération
même ceux qui étaient contre lui à des
moments où à d'autres savent que mon
père était une personne droite intègre
et ce qu'il a fait là c'est juste abject
mais comme tout le reste tout le reste
est depuis des années quand vous
entendez gwendal esprits en tout dix
mots juste que quand j'ai entendu ça et
que surtout quand j'entends il savait et
beaucoup savaient à l'intérieur parce
que je me dis c'est avec autant d'années
comment se fait-il que les pages journée
ne se soit pas arrivée ne serait ce que
vous les journalistes ont parlé à chaque
élection de la fédération française des
sports de glace tous les journalistes
l'équipe en premier fait un papier sur
didier gailhaguet vous avez cette image
le grand public vous dites gailhaguet
c'est pas une image de champion vous
avez une société b ccc par les problèmes
oui nous connaissaient mal reconnaissait
pas fall et les mots n'ont pas été
vraiment 18 voyez ce que je veux y en a
il y en a eu je peux vous assurer
reprenez des papiers de deux de
nombreuses années en partie de qu'une
loi nouvelle carte à jamais et
patineuses qui vous a dit voilà j'ai eu
des problèmes avec cet entraîneur luc
beyer où il a eu des comportements
bizarres ou jamais jamais jamais alors
si aimé assez récemment
oui une amie proche dominique denuault
sur sur des du harcèlement psychologique
pas de viol la levée du harcèlement
psychologique au quotidien c'était plus
une enfant elle travaillait avec lui au
centre de bercy ce sont des français
volants elle était elle était entraîneur
à ses côtés et c'était au quotidien
l'impossibilité de vivre une vie libre
c'est à dire que dès qu'elle avait un
petit copain il faisait en sorte que ça
n'existe plus si c'était quelqu'un qui
était au sein du club il les vins c'est
et et elle a vécu sous se joue de
gilbert celui ci encore pendant des
années les le harcèlement et les
violences psychologiques sont en train
de sortir maintenant on commence à en
entendre parler parce que justement les
langues se délient
pourquoi personne ne parlait pas ce que
tout le monde a quelque chose à perdre
que ce soit ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sa passion son boulot le vivien
roland frère de haenlin roland celle qui
a qui a
donc permis de mettre monsieur delorme
en prison pendant dix ans parce qu'elle
a été violée elle aussi son frère son
propre frère m'a aidé pendant les douze
étaient dans cette équipe que nous
avions ensemble lors de 2014
à la suite de ça il a et il a subi il
n'a pas il était technicien contrôleur
technicien sur des compétitions à
l'international pendant six mois il n'a
plus pu le faire ensuite on lui a fait
ça en national et il a finalement perdu
son boulot d'entraîneur à nice voilà
gwendal est ce que vous êtes plus que
vous souhaiteriez aujourd'hui voilà
qu'est ce qui ce qui se passe quoi ce
que ce que ce que la ministre a prévu
c'est à dire que l émission données
légales et on s'en fout de la démission
de didier gailhaguet
pourquoi parce qu'il a déjà démissionné
par le passé l'important c'est pas qui
part sûreté qui ne reviennent jamais
jamais on s'en fout de sa démission
ce qu'il faut c'est que c'est que madame
madame la ministre
concil continue ce programme qu'elle a
de retirer le la délégation de pouvoir à
la fédération française des sports de
glace
elle est le comité olympique ont assuré
aussi bien aux clubs cause qu aux
entraîneurs et aux patineurs que toute
la continuelle nie toute la continuité
allait pouvoir se faire que les
patineurs pourrait participer aux
championnats du monde que les clubs
pourraient continuer à recevoir leurs
licenciés sans problème tout ça c'est
cetc déjà pensé réfléchi ça peut tenir
jusqu'à la la fin de l'année et ensuite
ce qu'il faut c'est table rase de cette
fédération elle n'existe plus à régler
on fait une une sidération 2.0 une
fédération qui peut-être ne reprend pas
le schéma des de l'association de loi
1901 1901 juste gone gone la marche pour
plein de choses mais peut-être pas pour
une fédération où ça on l'a reçu il ya
deux jours elle est comment vous la
sentez sarr vous l'avez toujours senti
blessé
non c'est ça qui est hyper tragique pour
nous et qu'elle dure à voir c'est le
petit soleil de de l'équipe de france
sarah c'est toujours celle qui sourit
qui faisait les blagues qui était qui
était toujours joyeuse
et aujourd'hui on ce qu'on a vécu avec
elle pendant des années ça c'est clair
sous un jour qui est violent c'est à
dire qu'on imagine tout ce qu'elle a
vécu derrière parce qu'elle a dû enfouir
et et toute cette bonne humeur et toute
cette bonhomie de sarah c'était juste un
manteau un manteau de protection et
surtout un appel à la protection sur sa
race
moi je l'appelle picard pikachu c'était
même un petit catch où vous avez vu
qu'en pikachu cnr a mis la bombe la ptme
elle a mis des années et des années
avant de s'énerver et pia le disait
toujours la pauvre sarah des qui lui
arrive est un petit truc à elle disait
la pauvre sarah ça nous faisait rigoler
mais en fait quand on l'a on réentend
dans nos oreilles aujourd'hui la pauvre
sarah wayne a pas qu'eux on voit qu'il y
avait c'était un appel à l'aide a été
protégée mois soyez soyez mes grands
frères mais papa elle elle changeait les
lire les clés des chambres d'hôtel quand
on était sur la tournée équipe de france
pour que toutes les filles se retrouvent
au même endroit pour être sûr que allah
il y en a pas une qui soit isolée dans
l'hôtel regarder sous celui des
téléspectateurs
oui à 83% non à 17%